here is every Doublestar hunter in
Hunter Hunter I swear I say the word
Hunter way too much in these videos but
it's pretty unavoidable but what even is
a double star hunter well a single star
is awarded to a hunter who produces a
remarkable achievement in a particular
field we're talking about something that
would permanently solidify your name in
a history book it's so incredibly
difficult to achieve even one star but
two two stars that's 100% more
impossible because it has the added
criteria that a hunter must have
mentored at least one student who has
been awarded a star so it's not good
enough to just go and revolutionize
Humanity on your own no you also need to
essentially raise someone else to do
exactly the same so you need to repeat
your achievement but with far less
control and we actually have a case of
this in process in the mongre the moment
in chapter 326 moral is noted as one of
the election candidates and he's
currently a single star hunter but the
narrator said that his promotion
directly to a triple star hunter may be
imminent and we'll go through the
criteria for Triple Star Hunters as well
however this this implies that moral
students knuckle and or shoot are also
being considered for promotion to single
star Hunters likely for their
contribution in quite literally saving
the world during the Chimera an talk
there's also one extra criteria for a
double star hunter which is that the
candidate needs to hold or have held an
official position within the hunter
Association and that's probably the big
incentive for becoming examiners for the
hunter exam just because it's a box that
needs to be ticked for a potential
promotion later otherwise there's not a
whole lot of incentive in giving your
time to become an examiner but there are
six phom six confirmed double star
hunters in this world and we are going
to begin with one biscuit Krueger now
bisy is far older than both her Lolly
and her muscular form would have you
think she's 57 and one of the most
prolific hunters in the association
today this is despite the fact that
she's incredibly selfish and does very
little for the association itself at
least not so much these days on Greed
Island bisy revealed that she has
actually held at least one official
position as an examiner for the hunter
exam we don't know what stage it was or
what bisy cooked up but she described
the experience of quote fun which leads
me to believe that it was very not that
but when it comes to bisy it must be
noted that she is a student of the
shingen Ryu School of Kungfu which is
the martial arts Dojo founded by Isaac
netra although it's unconfirmed as to
whether or not he was the one who
actually trained bisy one fun fact about
the shingen Ryu School of kung fu was
that there are only three known
practitioners of this style netro bisy
and wing and those are the only three
characters who kilaa has ever severely
underestimated so whatever that their
school has going on it's designed to be
capable of in a trained zelic assassin
now speaking of wing he was trained by
bisy however as far as we know he isn't
a St Hunter and also the way bisy talks
about him nicknaming him fledgling wing
and stuff doesn't give me a whole lot of
confidence that Wing has climbed too far
up the association hierarchy meaning
that bisy may have had another student
reached that Accolade leading to her own
promotion and of all the other one-star
candidates we know I honestly wouldn't
be too surprised if it was Cutie Beauty
mostly because bisy and Beauty have
shared interest in remaining youthful
and vibrant however it might also be an
unnamed star hun Hunter because there
does seem to be a bit of a pattern where
shingen Ryu students Mentor other
students but then again bisy has
demonstrated that she's not overly picky
when choosing her students particularly
when she non-consensually decided to
take both gon and kilwa as students in
chapter 137 in terms of bis's remarkable
achievement well as a ston hunter I can
only imagine that bisy managed to
discover a long lost treasure or even a
never known and therefore never lost
natural treasure but the achievement
doesn't necessarily need to be in the
Hunter's primary field it just makes
much more sense for for it to be but I
say that because bisy also could have
had quite an impact on the beauty and
anti-aging world I'm imagining something
like being able to produce and sell a
water down version of her magical Spar
services and N ability also this video
is sponsored by better help a platform
designed to connect you with a licensed
therapist train to listen and provide
you with helpful unbiased advice because
starting therapy is difficult and
finding the right therapist made that
that can be particularly difficult
especially if they're not in your area
or they're booked up months in advance
but better H can match you to one one of
over 30,000 therapists in the network
with sessions availabl phone calls live
chats messaging whatever works best for
you at whatever time is most convenient
VI which I like because I'm a big fan of
convenience and as a pretty profound
introvert I'm also not a huge fan of
face to-face interactions so this is
very much a win-win for me as well as a
win for the over 4 million people who
have already used better help to start
healthy happier lives and you can do the
same through my link in the description
to get started you just need to fill out
a questionnaire describing your specific
needs and in most cases you'll be match
with your therapist within 48 hours and
if the therapist you're matched with
doesn't quite feel like the right fit
which is quite common when starting
therapy it's not a problem but in that
case you can easily switch to a new one
at no additional cost and no stressing
about networks and insurance and any of
the all of the things so if you think
you might benefit from therapy then
consider better help and if you visit
through my link in the description then
you will get 10% off your first month of
better help thanks so much again to
better help for helping to support this
channel so give better help a go and see
if it's the right fit for you but for
now it's back to you me next up we have
Doublestar Hunter misi sto Nana a crime
Hunter which is different from Blacklist
Hunters the latter specifically focuses
on Pursuits in the Underworld and that
generally consists of apprehending
criminals or Contraband but a crime
Hunter is more like a fancy investigator
M storm quite specifically hunts for
mysterious cases throughout the world's
solve you could even think of him as
Sherlock Holmes if he was dressed more
like a Cowman so the reason why he's
dressed like a cow is because he is of
course a member of The Zodiacs and they
all mimic their fun animal themes to
some degree m is just more well more
overt about it than most but that's a
very easy check mark for double star
hunter criteria not only has misi stor
held an official position but he's held
the highest position possible aside from
Vice chairman and chairman in fact misom
is deemed such an essential element of
the hunter Association that he has
actively been referred to as the
Zodiac's conscience and Common Sense
meaning that without him it's entirely
possible that the association becomes a
bit of a twisted entity and begins
affecting the world in very unpleasant
ways in addition to his chosen field
field of hunted them and official
capacity within the association misor is
also a qualified lawyer and manager of
his own private security company all of
which comes together in his hatu cross
game whereby he uses a series of cards
to both restrain and admit targets into
his quote courtroom when it comes to his
remarkable achievements it would seem
likely that misor has contributed to the
World by solving an incredibly difficult
case or perhaps even a series of cases
cases plural that led to a significant
outcome however with Mom's final
criteria it's difficult to figure out
who his student may have been firstly
because misi stor himself is a bit of a
classic loner he generally does his best
work as a single party but also because
none of the single star Hunters really
cross into his field at all the closest
is probably the hacker Hunter ampe but I
think that he may have been someone
else's student someone who will get to
and I suppose it also may have been
bushor ambitious because he and M ior
share a love of the general Law and
Order but then again I think the bushie
door may have also been the student of
someone else on this list so that leaves
out Cal without a com off so I'm left to
conclude that we have yet to meet misor
student now as for who I think was Bushi
Dora's Mentor that would be double star
hunter terod neutral you'll probably
remember him as the guy who was there
and then promptly wasn't there during
the chairman election Arc he's a really
really unfortunate character and in my
opinion a bit of a victim of Togashi
getting bored of his story immediately
after introducing the shortlived terod
Dame plotline which is a little
frustrating because he's introduced as
the new leader of the pure Paladin Squad
and trying to explain what that is look
it takes us down a very dangerous rabbit
hole that could probably be a whole
video of its own but it's a mysterious
yet very well-known subsection of the
hunter Association that was one said by
Isaac netro as all things seem to have
been if you're keeping track he was the
chairman of the hunter Association the
founder of the shingen Ryu dojo and
leader of the pure Paladin Squad and
exactly what that group did well it's
left tantalizingly in the shadows but at
some stage it had to be disbanded due to
reasons and P of teran's big election
pitch is that despite being described as
the anti-et action he plans to reinstate
the pure Paladin Squad which I take to
mean that this squad may have been an
internal Hunter police force but it
could also have been many many other
things the point is that terane is
killed so quickly that we don't even
have the opportunity to dive too deeply
into it trodan is killed by Hoka which I
think is important to linger on for a
bit because it emphasizes that becoming
a single double or perhaps even Triple
Star Hunter is not especially dependent
on combat ability it's about how a
hunter applies themselves to their
particular field and not everyone's
special interest is punch fighting in
fact herodan special was head hunting
which while it does sound quite violent
means that he dedicated his career to
sourcing and cultivating new Talent
which is absolutely perfect for a
Doublestar Hunter because no matter what
kind of Hunter you are to reach this
level you need to source and cultivate a
talent and in this case I think it's
highly likely that terod Dain achieved
his single star status by initiating
many of the association's biggest names
and achieved his double star license
when his likely student bushida was
awarded his single star thus qualifying
trodan not that it matters because
they're both dead now now for some less
dead but who probably should be he is by
far the most curious double star hunter
lene UV a woman who today physically
resembles in OV but was a close
companion of Isaac netro during his and
I suppose her youth in fact Len is one
of two confirmed living people who have
survived a trip to the Dark Continent
with the other being neto's son Beyond
so just like Neto it's impossible to
exactly pinpoint Len's age all we know
is that she has been referred to as the
oldest member of the hunter Association
so going by neto's age that's what like
over his century but then the question
becomes how many of the centuries
because that's what that sweet sweet
dark consonant Nitro rice does it gives
humans the ability to live potentially
as long as they want but Lin is a gour
May Hunter which makes finding her
student incredibly easy it's highly
likely that Lin mentored the single star
hunter Menchi from way back during the
Hunter xamar and I love that Len is a
gouret hunter because it means that she
would have gone to the Dark Continent
with the goal of finding new and exotic
ingredients with which to create dishes
and that very well could be how Len was
able to to achieve her single star if
she found something on the Dark
Continent anything perhaps even
something as simple as a herb even a
herb could go on to revolutionize
Humanity in somewhere because every
Speck of dirt on the Dark Continent
seems to be able to either revolutionize
or completely wipe out Humanity we also
don't know what Len's official role
within the association is/ was in fact
when we caught up with her during the
election Arc it was stated that no one
had even heard her voice in 5 years but
I'd say that in her younger days lene at
least served as an examiner at some
point but she's so old and was so
attached to netro that it really could
have been any number of roles but what's
this is that a horse I hear clip
clopping no it's just Sono kobayakawa
the double star horse Hunter zodiac
often mistaken for the rat because of
the teeth however pariston he is the rat
sacho has one of the more Curious
Pursuits that we've seen from a hunter
because he is a problem Hunter and
exactly what that is then that's never
elaborated on we really have no idea
what he does because problems appear in
all aspects of life one day Sao could be
contracted to figure out the logistics
of building a giant whaleboat to sail
the Dark Continent and then the very
next day he could be a marriage
counselor we don't know Sacha might even
hunt for problems in order to shed light
on them before anyone even realizes that
it's going to become a problem sort of
like taking risk assessments to the
extreme what we do know is that he is
exceptionally powerful because his name
is taken from the kobayakawa clan a very
historically renowned group of Samurai
that's not very helpful in terms of
pinpointing his one-star student though
in fact we can't even accurately
ascertain what kind of person sacho is
because he belongs to the apolitical
Trio in The Zodiacs along with jel and
Kanai so Sancho is going to have to
remain a bit of a mysterious double star
hunter just just for now much less of a
mystery is double star hunter Jing
freaks a man who's notoriously po
fathering is the entire reason why
Hunter Hunter begins however despite the
fact that most people within the
association and I guess the world and
large don't like Jing they all respect
him and he even mentored kite one of the
greatest Hunters we've ever met although
he does not appear to have single star
status instead I think that Jing may
have mentored shampe who is a single
star Hunter and likely assisted Jing in
building Greed Island along with Razer
another man that Jing mentored into
serving his own personal purposes Jing
is of course a ruins Hunter who has
dedicated his life to uncovering and
preserving ancient ruins although I feel
like I use the word dedicated
incorrectly Jing does whatever the crap
it is the Jing wants to do and that
often involves ruins but seemingly
equally if not more often it doesn't and
that's why it's difficult to talk about
Jing as a double star hunter because
that's only a technicality kite even
said that Jing should be a triple star
hunter and the only reason why he isn't
is because he hasn't been bothered to
fill out the application form so just
what has Jing done to earn that right
and who were the other three known
Triple Star hunters in the world well
we're going to cover the Pinnacle of the
hunter Association in the next video